so new york new york was taken out of
text and you know yeah that song was
never meant to be a slight to new york
correct not at all and the video
i think i don't even think it was much
about the song as much it was about the
video
that was after we got shot at
um so so that so you guys got shot at
and then you guys did the video the way
you did the video yeah
so the video was meant to be like a [ __ ]
you but the song itself originally was
not meant to be a like a [ __ ]
you know the first scenes was in times
square we wouldn't go to new york to
shoot the video i mean we had balls but
not that much but right right yeah i'm
saying new york in the night is a wild
place
guys was cat as was la it's the capital
but new york
new york is like los angeles they had
the gangs original gangs right you know
what i'm saying is out of new york city
so
you know what i'm saying like chicago
you know what i'm saying you know
so we we thought actually new york would
accept it it's a mellie mel chorus
melanie mellon the furious 5 grandmaster
flash
you know melly mel cleared it
you know what i'm saying got paid
so we was like melanie mel cleared it oh
well
dang we finally gonna get the respect
we're gonna get new york to love they're
gonna love us for this
when we you know put this one out
they're gonna love us you know what i'm
saying and when we drop dog food nobody
made a fuss about new york new york our
first single was let's play house
so
the album was already out nobody was
making a fuss like we was this in new
york and everybody liked new york new
york that's why i became the next video
and
we said we're going to shoot this in
time we're going to shoot this in times
square in new york
oh man we're finally going to get the
love
that you know as much as we love new
york new york is finally going to love
us this song is dedicated to them and
we're going to get respect as mcs
corrupt you leading that way
for them to to love
yeah i'm saying i was like wow
this is going to be historic so we fly
out there we flew out the low riders and
you know it was a big deal to us and
we invited everybody come through and
and let's all get down and
you know come be in the video and let's
show them this unification
only one that really showed up was monie
love
you know she showed up gave us some love
um
nobody else showed up a couple people
though we had uh case slopes que solo
building he always [ __ ] with us though
you know and a couple other people came
and showed love but
you know so you guys had originally
intended to invite a bunch of people
from new york to new york we sent a
shout out to
all of new york you know coming through
shooting this video dedicated to y'all
type of vibe
and they really didn't feel that way
and then uh after we shot in times
square we shot in
red hook brooklyn
and you know a couple
shells went through our trailer
nobody got hurt but our pride
did so you know
we stopped everything got up out of
there we got home we was down for a bit
and then we just was like uh we can't go
for this
that's where you came up with the new
video i think we're dissing them
we're gonna show you this
and then
the whole
[Music]
dynamics and direction of the video
changed
and that's when we did all of that right
there
yeah that was an interesting video and
an interesting time too because then i
know
you know shout out to uh capone and
noriega cnn did their yeah they were
there la la la la which was you know
it was it was it was a wild time to be
around i'm sure be around death talk to
nora about it i think we was on um
we was on a drink championship yeah
shots were talking about that and
um you know norway was you know he's so
funny oh he's hilarious oh yeah he's the
best
nori was one of the first that i linked
up with
who uh we became very good close friends